lui c'est qu'il a de porc comme il est
de la haute
il est beau très beau on n'avait pas dit
quoi il est dès qu'ils n'étaient quoi
qu'en entrevue
[Musique]
le médecin du pays et populations comme
très bien au contraire et même rice
affaires confrères de las vegas une
situation magnifique
vous auriez dû repartir couvert d'or la
population de saint maurice est bien
portante des gens bien portants sont les
malades qui s'ignorent monsieur le maire
le docteur non voilà qui devrait donner
mardi une consultation entièrement
gratuit gratuitement cinq as quelque
chose des tas n'est pas normal puisque
l'état à ce titre je me dois d'abord à
mes clients le docteur par paliers
d'idées mais bastian 4 ma vie dit trois
villes
la maladie de mise partout même là où la
soupçonne pas mon fort très fort mais
c'est ce même trop il ya des fois tu que
ce sont des démangeaisons ici et que ce
serait pas plutôt dollar à à oui ça me
chatouille ou plusieurs armes gratouille
ne confondons pas ça vous chatouille on
sert vous gratouille
[Musique]
les travaux de j
genre
en vain
[Musique]
m
et le petit hôtel
vous savez quand j'en sais avec lucas
un peu
et puis quand on dit ça vous avez écrit
ce à la mecque de plaisir
c'est drôle simplement dit ville et
enfin comme pour l'écurie il
donnez moi la force de lutter contre le
mal qu'ils gagnent que maurice aidez-moi
démasquer les imposteurs
tu vois koné aurait des choses à
raconter ça serait pas bonne impression
ça ton assez de petits merdeux
j'ai appris son passé criminel
tu as un menteur
oui kim a connu hier des milliers à y
remédier pour ne pas mourir de parfait
alors ça y est la partie beaucoup de
paramètres
besoin de 406 a c'est que l'afrique
existence paisible était pas quel
bonheur est gaza nos troupes en europe
ne semble pas l'avoir aidé les mets pas
les pieds
tout simplement
[Musique]